but she goes and tells all the Muslims
that the Americans haters the white
people haters and they are so entire
Islamists and their that the islamaphobe
that the term that was invented by care
yeah so we've talked about this a bunch
of the show but can you explain why the
term specifically Islamophobe was
invented and why it's such a confusing
term to counterpart the anti-semitism so
it's easier to say Islamophobe so you
could okay if you are an Islamophobe
that's why you're with with others that
hate all the Muslims in the United
States well number one if they hated all
the Muslims I've been here three decades
as an adult yeah how come nobody hated
I went to her district and I spoke to
the people and I was going back and
forth back and forth spending time there
and even sometimes on Twitter I would
say I'm going to be in this place from
this time to it
come and meet me journalists and others
so I had all this research about this
district way before anything else and
then six months ago I decided to move
there and I started thinking that if I
run I would be the best the only
candidate that could beat her because of
my background I'm immune to her brand of
identity politics so I can push straight
for the important issues and important
discussions and I'm not a shy person at
all and I could say you are one two
three why did you meet turkish President
Erdogan before you were elected what
promises did you did you give him why
you refuse to acknowledge the the
Turkish ethnic cleansing against the
Armenians
why were you outraged because President
Trump decided to take justice to custom
soleimani why are you close to the
Muslim Brotherhood how much money have
you been getting from care through or
through care from Qatar and from the
godfather of the Muslim Brotherhood I
could do what no other candidates could
basically because if you tell her this
you're white supremacists yeah yeah yeah
yeah your time was left
she cannot accuse me of that well she
can't accuse you of it and I'm sure she
will accuse you of it it's not very
credible yeah because I grew up and
probably I know more about
then she does most likely yeah do you
sense she's using religion as a shield
of Laura she's using everything and she
has this victim card that she throws at
you oh I was five I have PTSD I was five
years old and no girl should live at war
because any war and everywhere around
the globe it's because of the United
States so what can you talk a little bit
about the tactics so you mentioned this
Muslim Brotherhood Care Connection we
mentioned we talked briefly before we
started about Brigitte Gabriel who's
really been laying this thing out for
years what the plan is to infiltrate
you're not saying there's over 100
candidates that are being groomed by
them but I think one of the tactics
which you sort of hit on is this
constant desire to make everything feel
crazy all the time and it almost seems
like every time to leave in a way
Rasheed is who he is almost worse than
Ilhan in this way that everything she
says seems to be designed to make
maximum chaos and and is that really
part of what they do that's the main
thing that they do and that's how they
get support I mean in HoN Omar or
Rashida clabe let me talk about each one
because they have similar tactics but on
different issues like al hahn Omar when
she keeps feeding or tweeting or saying
the same narrative over and over and
over that I represent every Muslim in
the country first she's supposed to
represent the fifth District she's
supposed to serve the fig the fifth
District and she's done zero nada
nothing so when she goes and tells all
the Muslims that the Americans haters
the white people haters and there are so
entire Islamists and there that the
Islamophobe that the term that was
invented by care yeah
we've talked about this a bunch of the
show but can you explain why the term
specifically Islamophobe was invented
and why it's such a confusing term to
counterpart the anti-semitism so it's
easier to say Islamophobe so you could
okay if you are an Islamophobe that's
why you're with with others that hate
all the Muslims in the United States
well number one if they hated all the
Muslims I've been here three decades as
an adult yeah
how come nobody hated me well I'm sure
this is the difference people probably
hate you for your ideas now Ilhan is
probably not thrilled with you I doubt
that but even after 9/11 like nine
twelve I have never felt threatened
because I was a Muslim I'm an American
regardless of Ovie's I don't use this
and the problem is or I'm forced to use
a Muslim former refugee immigrants just
to the identity politics that she uses
and I stated it once on Twitter that was
picked up by everybody because she said
I am a job which is that is not the
right to job that she claims to and I've
spoken to several American Somalis that
this is not the Muslims a job I mean she
wears the hijab
regarde based on the people that she's
meeting she's meeting Muslims she would
cover but her job as a ninja you cannot
show your chest you cannot show your
hands it's it's it's all it's Muslims
know that right well also plenty of the
policies that she's for would not be
policies that if you were a strict
Muslim you would be for like help
abortion is a right yes well I'm sorry
abortion is health care exactly okay and
it's human rights as well so but the
problem with the people in the district
that they don't follow what
she does MDC only daily basis they don't
know that she missed half half of the
votes that anyone else in the house
she doesn't vote for the district you
know when she votes when it comes to
foreign policies that's why in her votes
and can you believe that she voted
against sending aides to to soma
at Somalia and then she went outside ten
minutes later
giving a press conference saying oh we
did it I mean this woman is filled with
lies and again her worst um mistake that
she didn't give me the interview and
that what made me go back and forth and
that what made me decide that I am gonna
cross the line between being a
journalist to a politician so what are
some of the other tactics that they use
besides that just general there they
want to cause chaos all the time and
seem to always everything they say seems
to be designed to deepen that divide
what else what else are they doing the
free handouts that it on reality doesn't
work
how could you give free health care to
everybody it doesn't work this way I
mean where would they get the money from
how could you forgive all the student
loans what would they do for people that
already pay their loans yeah we're not
getting anything back yeah yeah ooh how
I mean all these handouts and like free
this and free this and everybody is
gonna have a free house and it's gonna
have a friend I mean this is ridiculous
we are not in China and even in China
they don't do that that's right so but
can you explain a little bit more how
the Islamists and and care and Muslim
Brotherhood how they use the
progressives like it's like because this
is what I think a lot of people a lot of
people see this match made in hell
you're supposed to be progressive but
all these other values are completely
anti progressive but I don't think
people really understand
and how this thing fully ties together
because the progressive don't have minds
their right mind the Muslim Brotherhood
is using the far left and the
progressive for their own adjectives
they're not doing it for the sake of the
far left or the sake of progressive no
they are using them big time if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell